as an aerobics instructor dances armored
vehicles block off parliament in
myanmar's capital nepal on february the
first
but if the generals thought it would be
a bloodless coup they couldn't have been
more wrong
months of bitter resistance and a
violent military crackdown with nearly a
thousand killed
six months later the military junta is
renaming itself a caretaker government
although it appears it will still hold
important positions and the leading
general giving assurances elections will
be held soon
[Music]
we must create conditions to hold a free
and fair multi-party general election
we have to make the preparations i
pledge to hold the multi-party general
election without fail
but it's not clear under what conditions
those elections would be held
since the coup the military has outlawed
the national league for democracy aung
san tsuchi's party and rejected its
landslide victory in november new
elections would take place under the
military's emergency laws which will be
in place for another two years
minong laid did say the military would
follow the lead of an envoy sent by the
association of south east asian nations
but that envoy has yet to be appointed
and asean has failed to take a firm line
as events have spiraled out of control
asean has been divided on myanmar in the
last six months with indonesia malaysia
and singapore wanting to take a hard
line but the generals here in bangkok
appear to be wanting to give the benefit
of the doubt to the generals in myanmar
what is of growing concern to the
international community is the worsening
covert 19 situation in the country more
than half of the world's population
lives in countries bordering myanmar
while inside those borders the virus is
spreading unchecked
the coup has resulted in a
near total collapse of the health care
system and healthcare workers are being
attacked and arrested
the virus is spreading
through the population very fast indeed
by some estimates in the next two weeks
half of the population of myanmar could
be infected with kovid
on the streets of yangon protesters set
fire to myanmar's plague
they say they don't want new elections
they just want the military to step down
tony chang al jazeera bangkok
let's not bring in cho win who's the
executive director of the burma human
rights network he's joining us on skype
from london thanks for your time with us
on al jazeera so what do you make of the
head of the
the military uh seemingly rebranding
himself and taking on this new role of
prime minister
uh this is the playing by old book
because you see if you see the 1962 the
how the military coups there's a power
at the time and then they changed to
caretaker government and then they ruled
for 26 years so that is what the same
situation going to happen when the
military kuta power they said that they
are going to conduct the election very
soon by one year but not only three and
the same way they're dragging the time
bit by bit so
the the main the key point here is they
are not going to
you know lead the power soon
how do you think uh this is this will be
viewed by people in myanmar
well the people is from the day one we
are against that and we are supporting
ndg government
and uh the people uh you know uh the
people of burma who
voted for the uh in 2020 for the uh you
know
an ali party is standing uh on their on
their commitment and they're they're you
know still we are supporting to energy
government who is you know um supported
by all the minorities and majorities in
population in burma but the point here
is you see that
the military is trying to fool
international community ahead of uh uh
unga in in into in in september
so they're trying to show that that this
give a government is a legitimate
showing to the legitimacy but but
actually the people has rejected and
bear in mind that that
the coup is still underway it's not
achieved yet what they are trying to do
so
it is important point to highlight right
and speaking of the international
community particularly the asean
countries who will be holding a meeting
tomorrow to decide on an envoy for
myanmar
is that significant at all or
how do you expect that to play out or
will it pressure the military in any way
to change its course
see that because of the russia and china
backing the burmese military and also
asean is divided it is not going to have
any significant
impact on them but the point is uh the
the
one of the unfortunate situation is the
international community is throwing
buckets on the head of asean it's not
right way to you know to
pushing all the solutions towards asean
that's not the right way but it is
important that international communities
such as uh you know world powers need to
be united uh but it is not going to
happen if you see the
u.n security council so this is all
benefiting that military to you know to
to take control the power but before
that what is the most important point
here i would like to highlight this is
the same military committed genocide in
2017 according to u.n fact-finding
mission and this is the same military is
committing crime against humanity as we
obama human rights network on 29th of
july a couple of days ago we publish a
report we have properly thoroughly did
the research and we clearly find out
that this is the military operation has
very systematic and very widespread they
conducted the crime against humanity in
burma and the prime is currently
continued if you see look at the if you
look at the kovic situation the way the
military is conducting is killing the
people the aim is to kill the people
thank you so much for speaking to us
from london
thank you very much